Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Loki season 2
is coming later this year we've got a couple of
teaser trailers and we just got Spider-Man across
the spider-verse learning how Marvel and Sony are
connecting a lot of the larger characters from
different Studios like different story cinematic
universes together heading up to Avengers six
Secret Wars a lot of the movie is dedicated to
connecting things with the traditional MCU Marvel
movies the Sony Spider-Man movies the fox Marvel
movies pretty much everything is being connected
through what was happening in the spider-verse in
what's happening during the Loki series especially
what's happening with the TVA in their hunt for
all the different kangs in the Council of Kangs
just in general so if you're brand new to the
channel I'll be doing weekly episode videos for
Loki season 2 like I did for season one so be sure
to subscribe to get everything and of course the
next part of Spider-Man across the spider-verse
which is called Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
will release in March 2024 so we don't have to
wait that long to get it we'll start getting some
teaser trailers for that pretty soon too careful
for spoilers for across the spiderverse if you
haven't seen it yet just because we we do need
to talk about everything that happens during the
movie but during the movie Spider-Man 2099 reveals
that he's created his own version of the TVA
basically with alternate versions of Spider-Man
from different universes trying to protect what he
calls the Canon of Spider-Man basically his word
for describing a sacred timeline the same way that
he who remains Kang called his own timeline the
sacred timeline the spider-verse Canon timeline
as he shows miles here looks exactly the same
way that they depict the timeline during the Loki
series that's not meant to be a coincidence that's
on purpose this everything everything they are
the Canon chapters that are a part of every Spider
story every time in this version of their sacred
timeline every version of Spider-Man is meant to
have a version of a tragic backstory with someone
close to them dying from the classic Comics or
in the case of spider Gwen a small Twist on that
where instead of an Uncle Ben or a captain Stacy
it's a Peter Parker who became the lizard instead
of Kurt Connors dying giving them all their origin
story so that they become versions of Spider-Man
using Loki in the tba's way of describing this
the circumstances of Miles morales's origin
story make his spider bite a Nexus event
up and off your path created a Nexus event which
left unchecked could Branch off into madness lead
into another multiversal War before they learned
the truth during Loki season 1 the TVA believes
that Nexus events left unchecked left unpruned
will cause the collapse of the Multiverse the
truth that they wind up learning was that that
was a lie he who remains Kang revealed that Nexus
events were simply what he called timelines
that branched out and led to the creation
or led to the rise of dangerous Kang variants
Spider-Man 2099 is operating the same way that
the TVA like Mobius those characters were before
they learned the truth during the movie they talk
about the term spider-verse the web of life and
Destiny Miles Morales in the movie coins the term
spider-verse but it's just a way of describing the
cosmic connections between universes in Spider-Man
2099 incorrectly believes that things have to
play out a certain way otherwise it will lead to
the destruction of all reality just like the TVA
characters before the the events of Loki season
1. during the movie he uses his history trying to
move to the alternate universe where his family
was still alive and assumed the identity of that
universe's version of Miguel when that Universe
collapses he incorrectly assumes it's because
of what he did try to exist in the alternate
universe where he wasn't originally supposed to be
but again he's making a false assumption because
he doesn't know anything about the Council of
Kang's the Kang Multiverse War the incursions
and the new Kang Multiverse War that's coming
in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty with the dynasty of
Kangs the Council of Kangs Waging War against all
the Avengers anyone else from the Multiverse that
actually challenges them so Spider-Man 2099
didn't accidentally destroy that alternate
universe himself because of what he was doing
it was destroyed because the Council of Kangs
destroyed it the Council of Kangs does pretty
much a version of what he who remains Kang did
before he was killed they try to prevent timelines
from rising up that could propagate something or
someone capable of challenging them which is why
during the Ant-Man the Lost Mania post-credits
scene the Council of Kangs is witnessing all the
things that happened the last couple of Marvel
movies with the incursions in the Multiverse
they decide that the MCU Universe has become a
threat in some similar universes and they decide
to move against them like it's time to destroy
their timeline Spider-Man 2099 hasn't learned the
truth yet so he's still acting the way that Mobius
the TVA did before they learned the truth trying
to protect what he believes the sacred timeline
to be even though that's a lie even though Miles
Morales and the other characters haven't learned
about the Council of Kangs yet as far as we know
things can be very different Miles Morales is like
one of those alternate Loki's that we meet who
are bigger variants on the theme of the original
character they only got pruned because they came
from timelines where dangerous Kangs rose up it
wasn't because there was something wrong with them
on a cosmic level during the movie spider-gwen
proves the theory when she changes events in her
Universe causing her father Captain Stacy to quit
his job meaning that he ultimately won't be killed
in the line of duty like all the other captains
Stacy's at the Multiverse in why Miles Morales
won't cause all of reality to collapse just by
Saving his father's life from the spot who does
now have the ability to alter the Multiverse on
a cosmic level so the spot has become a Multiverse
threat now but Miles Morales is a lot like the new
version of Loki in that way he is a variant who
originally was going to be pruned and in reality
there's nothing wrong with him existing they won't
cause the collapse of their universes by changing
things the real threat to all of reality is the
spot who absorbed all that dark matter now he has
the power to alter all of reality he's kind of
like the beyonders during the more recent Secret
Wars event where they forcibly start destroying
the Multiverse because they think it sucks which
is what the spot is doing at the end of the movie
I'm gonna change all this I'm going to destroy it
because this sucks normally the TVA would prune
someone like the spot immediately the reason why
it seems like he's running around unchecked
is just because of the events of Loki season
2 during Loki season 2 the new kang variant 2
creates and manages the TVA this guy here isn't
supposed to be around like it's supposed to be
a big mystery when season two picks up what's
going on where is he when really what happened
is that he was called to the Council of Kangs to
help with their new kang Multiverse war against
the Avengers the other timelines and universes
that threatened their Supremacy so it's like the
boss is awaited an important meeting long term
leaving the mid-level managers like Mobius the
others to mine the store and Loki who's the only
person besides Sylvie who remembers that previous
version of the timeline and what's really going on
with the Council of Kangs basically has to recap
the events of season one to all these characters
like Mobius so they can start going after the real
threats to the stability of the Multiverse all the
different Kinks the Council of Kangs basically
enter that Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
post-credits scene where they're going after the
Victor timely kang that's literally meant to be
a scene taken from Loki season 2. I don't know
which episode but it feels like just based on
the tone is from earlier in the season Jonathan
Majors is supposed to be in multiple episodes as
different Kang variants it won't just be Victor
timely Kang I know there's tons of questions
about what's happening with him just in general
they're supposed to have changed the post-credits
scene for Loki season 2 that will explain a lot
of that so it'll be a couple more months but
we'll find out what's going on with that pretty
soon but the idea is that the next part of the
story for the spider-verse Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse Spider-Man 2099 will finally learn
the truth about what causes universes to collapse
and realize that Miles Morales is totally fine
existing and changing things the way that he was
talking about like saving his father's life just
like the new Loki variant is fine existing and
messing with stuff the other major connection
between what's happening in Loki season 2
in the spider-verse movies is that they're
using Spider-Man across the spider verse in the
next part of the story to literally connect all
those characters to the MCU live action stuff
in preparation for Avengers 6 Secret Wars where
there'll be a ton of Multiverse Cameo scenes
that's why they blend in so many live-action
elements and crossovers to the movie like the
doctor strange Tom Holland Spider-Man no way home
references the live-action Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man scenes we know that both Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield will come back in
secret Wars and if they weren't going to connect
all these characters together eventually in a much
bigger crossover there'd be no reason for mixing
in live action elements they would have animated
Toby Maguire they would have animated Andrew
Garfield don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth 1999
should still knows
did it work really early Theory too during
Secret Wars in place of the thoracore they'll
use the spider Force like a bunch of versions
of Spider-Man fighting on screen they'll just
give a couple of them like the main versions
speaking lines as part of all this do not be
surprised if there are bigger live-action Cameo
scenes in Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse from
Toby Maguire Tom Holland Andrew Garfield just
sort of confirming that they're moving things
along like oh yeah you're actually showing
up in the movie because there's going to
be a much bigger crossover coming in a couple
years in secret Wars just like they say during
the movie everything is connected literally
everything is connected if you have any other
questions about Hall this connects with the
Loki season 2 episodes the Council of kangs
in the spider-verse stuff let me know in
the comments I've got a bunch more videos
planned and we will get a Loki season 2 trailer
pretty soon too be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that a couple more
weeks and we'll get secret Invasion episodes
too everyone click here for my full Easter eggs
video for Spider-Man across the spiderverse there
are so many of them and click here for my post
could have seen an ending video for the movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!